Çeviri: Erman Turkmen
Gözden geçirme: Bilge Yilmaz
Denir ki her ülke ve her insan
kendini ötekiyle kimliklendirir.
Yani Avrupa kimliğinin oluşumunda
Müslüman Türklerin büyük yeri var.
O öteki.
O neyse ben o olmayanım.
Mesela Yunan kimliğinde
Türk'ün çok özel bir yeri var.
Türk neyse ben o olmayanım diye
bir kimlik inşa ediyor.
Buna tarihte öteki sorunu deniyor.
Bu çok önemli bir şey.
Biz Türkler de çok temiz olduğumuzu,
bütün Batılıların leş gibi pis olduğunu
onların koktuğunu falan söyleriz
sürekli olarak.
Hepimiz gerçekleri biliyoruz
ama öyle inanırız.
Şimdi bir adam var.
Bu adamı hepiniz tanıyorsunuz.
Bu adam dünyayı değiştiren
100 kişiden bir tanesi.
Bu adam kürenin yüz ölçümü ve
hacminin formülünü buldu.
Bileşik makara, sonsuz
ve hidrolik vidaları buldu.
Pi sayısının 3+1/7 ve 3+10/71
arasında olduğunu buldu.
Bu adam sonsuz küçüklerin yolunu açtı,
onu sonra Newton tamamladı.
Bu adam ilk denge prensiplerini buldu.
Kim bu?
Arşimet.
Ama biz onu bir şeyiyle biliyoruz,
suyun kaldırma kuvvetiyle.
Aslında o suyun kaldırma kuvvetini bulmadı
Onun bulduğu, suya daldırılan bir
nesnenin kendi hacmine eşit miktarda
sıvı hacminin yerini aldığı.
Yani demirle altının suyu taşırma
miktarı farklıdır.
Gümüşle altının farklıdır.
Dolayısıyla oradan da o meşhur aşağıda
gördüğünüz tacı buldu.
Peki soru şu?
Marifet hamamdaysa -hani hamama gitti de
buldu ya- binlerce yıldır milyonlarca Türk
hamamlara gitti de niçin biz suyun
kaldırma kuvvetini bulmadık?
Niye bulmadık?
Dünyanın başka yerlerinde de
hamamlar vardı.
Niye onlar bulmadı?
Demek ki marifet hamamda değil.
Bir soru daha size.
Tarihin en büyük bilim insanı kimdir?
Tahmini olan var mı?
Söyleyin.
Einstein, Da Vinci duydum. Başka?
Arkadaşlar, Isaac Asimov şöyle der:
"Kimin 2 numarada olduğunu sorarsanız
bu çok tartışılır ve muhtemelen
bunun yanıtı yoktur, çok aday vardır.
Ama kimin bir numara olduğunu sorarsanız
soru gayet nettir, cevabı da nettir."
Isaac Newton, tartışmasız dünyanın
bir numaralı bilim insanıdır.
Size bir kitap tavsiye edeyim.
Yeni baskısı yok, baskı yapıyorum
yeni baskıları yapılsın diye.
"En Etkin 100",
dünyayı değiştiren 100 kişi.
Bu yüz kişinin 1 numarası Hz. Muhammed,
2 numarası Newton, 3 numarası İsa.
Newton, bu kadar önemli bir insan.
Herkes ona diyor ki, işte bir elma düştü
ve Newton da buldu.
Değil mi?
Hamam gibi.
Arkadaşlar, Newton yüksek matematiğin
temelini attı.
Modern optiği kurdu.
Bugün hala kullandığımız teleskoplar
Newton prensibiyle çalışır.
Hala! İlk teleskopu da o yaptı,
aynalı teleskopu.
Hareket yasalarıyla modern fiziği başlattı
Newton kütle çekimle astronomiyi başlattı.
Ama 1665 veya 1666'da bir veba salgını
oldu Newton öğrenciyken.
Köylü, köyüne gönderildi
veba bulaşmasın diye.
Newton, köyde otururken
bir gece dolunay vardı.
Bir elma yere düştü ve
Newton kendine şu soruyu sordu.
Elma yere düşüyorsa Ay neden düşmüyor?
O gün bu soruya yanıt veremedi
çünkü elinde yüksek matematik yoktu.
Onu geliştirmesi gerekiyordu.
Bu arada Ay, Dünya'ya düşüyor.
Bunu da söyleyeyim size.
Ay Dünya'ya düşüyorsa, Dünya elmayı
ve Ay'ı nasıl kendine çekiyor?
Newton işte bunu buldu
ve dünya tarihini değiştirdi.
Peki marifet elmada ise, elmalar sadece
İngiltere'de mi yere düşüyor?
Niye Çin'de, Japonya'da,
Türkiye'de düşmüyor?
Düşüyorsa niye yer çekimini bulmuyorsunuz?
Siz, ben, başkaları.
Çünkü arkadaşlar başarı, onu arzulayan
ve ona hazır olana gelebilir.
Başarı, aşk gibidir.
Ben olduğum yerde duruyorum,
hiç dışarı çıkmıyorum,
CNN Türk'te oturuyorum sonra eve
gidiyorum sonra yine kanala gidiyorum
sonra yine eve gidiyorum
ve hayatımın aşkını arıyorum.
Bu mümkün mü?
Mümkün değil.
Dışarı çıkmam, onun peşinde koşmam lazım.
Başarı da öyle.
Hayatınızın aşkını bulmak için
dışarı çıkmanız gerektiği gibi
başarı için de arzulayacaksınız
ve onun peşinde koşacaksınız.
Newton hazırdı. Arşimet hazırdı.
Bunun üzerinde çalışmıştı,
onun için buldu.
Peki, Türkiye ve gelecek
uyumlu bir ikili midir?
İyi bir ikili midir?
Bir de buna bakalım hızlıca.
Türkiye'de okuma yazma bilmeyen
ne yazık ki 3,8 milyon insan var.
Danimarka'nın nüfusu 5,4 milyon.
Marifet nüfusta değil arkadaşlar.
İlkokul 5 yıllık ve altı
28,5 milyon insanımız var,
okuma yazma bilmeyenler de dahil.
Hollanda'nın nüfusu 16,5 milyon.
Bu insanları ne yapacaksınız,
nasıl sosyal güvenlik vereceksiniz?
Çocuklarını nasıl eğiteceksiniz?
Nasıl hastalık, emekli maaşı vereceksiniz?
Bu salondakiler çok çalışacak,
bu vatandaşlarımıza o hakları tanıyacağız.
Bir Hollandalı'nın 3 katı
çalışacaksınız siz.
Peki, bir PISA var.
Beni eskiden görenlerin aklına
dolar ne olacak gelirdi,
sanki ben onu bilebilirmişim gibi.
Bilsem kendim yaparım zaten.
Niye size söyleyeyim ya.
Ama şimdi beni görenlerin
aklına PISA geliyor.
PISA testi, 65 ülkede OECD
tarafından yapılıyor.
Her ülkenin kendi Milli Eğitim Bakanlığı
parasını veriyor.
15 yaşındaki çocuklara test yapıyoruz,
binlerce çocuğa test yapıyoruz.
Sonra da onları diğer ülkelerle
karşılaştırıyoruz ki sen senin ülkendeki
sorun ne, sen senin ülkendeki
sorun ne bunu anla.
Türk çocukları, 65 ülke içinde
fen bilimlerinde 43. arkadaşlar.
Matematikte kırk dördüncü.
Kendi dilinde okuduğunu anlama,
bakın Koreliler Korece, Japonlar Japonca,
Türkler Türkçe giriyorlar.
Yani İngilizce değil arkadaşlar.
Türkçe. Bu çocuklara Türkçe
eğitim veriyoruz.
Kendi dilinde okuduğunu
anlamada 65 ülke içinde
bizim çocuklarımız kırk ikinci.
Bütün bunlar toplanıp sıralama
yapıldığında da 45. sıraya düşüyoruz.
Arkadaşlar, fende 43. olan çocuk
sizi dünyanın en büyük 10 ekonomisi
içine sokabilir mi?
Matematikte 44. olan çocuk sizi
dünyanın en büyük 10 ekonomisi
içine sokabilir mi?
Çocuğun kendine hayrı yok.
(Gülüşmeler)
Ama bu çocuğun suçu mu arkadaşlar?
Çocuğun suçu değil.
(Alkış)
Neden değil? Ben size bir şey söyleyeyim.
Almanya, 1,5 milyon Türk'ten
dünya çapında futbolcu yetiştiriyor da
siz 76 milyondan yetiştiremiyorsunuz?
Çünkü sistem, bu çocuklar aptal değil.
Sistem aptal, biz aptalız.
Bu aptal sistemi çocuklara dayatıyoruz
ve bu sonuçları alıyoruz.
Ben size bir şey daha göstereyim.
Böyle olunca ne oluyor?
Arkadaşlar, yüksek teknoloji ihracatı
tablosu görüyorsunuz burada.
2000 yılında ve 2013 yılında.
Çin ekstrem bir ülke, onu saymayın
ama bir Kore'ye bakar mısınız?
130 milyar dolar yüksek teknoloji
ihracatı yapıyor.
2013 son veridir.
Türkiye, 1 milyar dolardan
2,2 milyar dolara çıkarmış
yüksek teknoloji ihracatını
Dünya Bankası verisine göre.
Türkiye diyor ki, benim yüksek
teknolojim 7,5 milyar dolar.
Peki niye Dünya Bankası böyle diyor?
Çünkü Dünya Bankası şöyle diyor:
Sevgili Türkiye, senin yüksek teknoloji
zannettiğin bazı şeyler,
yüksek teknoloji değil dostum.
(Gülüşmeler)
Arkadaşlar, bu çok acı bir şey.
Bunu yapmamız lazım
yoksa zenginleşemeyiz.
Bu çocuklar böyle kalırlarsa
benim emekli paramı ödeyemezler.
Sizinkini de ödeyemezler.
Bu çocuklar öyle kalırsa
bu ihracat büyümez.
Yüksek teknoloji
satamazsınız, üretemezsiniz.
Üretemezseniz de yoksul bir
ülke olarak kalırsınız.
Peki, bir şey daha var.
İstanbul Sanayi Odası her yıl Türkiye'nin
en büyük 500 şirketini açıklıyor.
Bu 500 şirketin burada sıralaması var.
Tamamı 500 değildir.
500 şirket içinde mesela madenciler de var
Onların ürettiği mal
yüksek teknoloji malı değil.
Yani üretimde yüksek teknoloji
kullanabilirsiniz ama ürettiğiniz malın da
yüksek teknoloji olması lazım.
Buradaki şey o.
Arkadaşlar, Türkiye'deki en büyük,
bakın en büyük 500 şirketimizin
186'sı en düşük teknolojili
malları üretiyor.
Türkiye'nin en büyük 500 şirketinin
163'ü düşük teknolojili mallar üretiyor.
Türkiye'nin 500 büyük firmasının sadece
109'u orta teknolojili mal üretiyor.
Türkiye'nin 500 şirketinin sadece 12'si
yüksek teknolojili mal üretiyor.
Bu, çok büyük bir ayıp.
Bu, çok büyük bir ayıp!
Bu hepimizin ayıbı.
Peki, bir şeye daha bakalım.
Hep Kore, Kore diyoruz. Biliyor musunuz
Kore - internette bulabilirsiniz-
1980'lerin ortasına kadar
Türkiye'den fakir bir ülke,
Türkiye'den geri bir ülke.
Biz 2023'te dünyanın en büyük 10
ekonomisi içine gireceğiz diyoruz ya,
arkadaşlar Goldman Sachs'ın 2050'ye kadar
dünya projeksiyonları var.
Değişir, değişmez ama şunu gösteriyor:
Kore, 2025 yılında 7. olacak,
Türkiye on altıncılıkta kalacak,
demin gördüğünüz nedenlerle.
Bu iş palavralarla olmuyor.
Gerçeği görmek lazım.
Teşhis koymazsanız tedavi yapamazsınız.
Önce teşhis koyacaksınız.
Ben kanserim, doktora diyorum ki
"bana kötü hastalık söyleme ne olur,
bir aspirin ver oradan"
ve iyi olmayı ümit ediyorum.
Mümkün mü?
Değil.
Mesela ben çok yakışıklıyım biliyorum,
"number 2"
Brad Pitt benden önce,
adam kaptı Angelina'yı.
Bir gitse Brad Pitt, ben "number 2"
olarak 1. olacağım,
Angelina'yı ben alacağım.
Teşhis var mı?
Var, şahaneyim. Değil mi?
Yok arkadaşlar. Kelim, çirkinim.
Biliyorum gerçeği, yüzleşmeliyim.
Kore ile gelişmiş ülkeleri
özellikle koydum.
Arkadaşlar, milyon kişiye düşen
-Türkiye'ye bakmayın, öbür tarafa bakın-
3.600, gelişmiş ülkelerde 5.900.
Neyi gösteriyor? Kore'nin hırsını.
Arkadaşlar Ar-GE harcaması
gelişmiş ülkelerde 2,47, Kore'de 4.
Neyi gösteriyor?
Kore'nin hırsını.
İhracatta yüksek teknolojinin
payı neyi gösteriyor?
Bir de bizimkine bakın.
Kore'nin hırsını.
Hırs, aynı zamanda akıl
ve bilimle birleşmeli.
Onun için bir şey yapmalısınız,
o çocukları yetiştirmelisiniz.
Başka yolunuz yok.
Şimdi, son 7 dakikamda size bir de
ekonomi de yeni bir dünya inşa ediliyor.
Ben buna Batı'lı, Hristiyan, üstün
beyaz adamın devri bitiyor diyorum.
Amerika hariç. Asya'ya kayıyor güç.
Bunu görüyorsunuz.
Yedi, sekiz yıldır ben de anlatıyorum.
Ama bir de bilimsel bir patlama var şu an.
Gerçek bir bilimsel patlama var.
Bunu görmüyorsunuz.
Dünya değişiyor.
Babalarınızla sizin aranızdaki
fark bu kadardı.
Babanızla dedeniz arasındaki
Ama benimle çocuğum arasındaki fark
bu kadar, torunumla aramdaki fark
ışık yılları olacak.
Neden?
Eski dünyada bilgi aritmetik
olarak artıyordu. 1-2-3-4 gibi.
Yeni dünyada artış geometrik.
2-4-8-16 gibi.
Nasıl?
Ben astronomiye çok meraklıyım, benden
önce bir şeyler gösterilince kıskandım.
10 yıl önce, evrenin haritasını
%50 doğrulukla yapıyorduk.
Bugün %90 doğrulukla yapıyoruz.
Bu size çok önemli gelmeyebilir
ama bir şey var.
Bu gördüğünüz teleskop,
altın oran denen bir teleskop.
Dünyadaki en önemli teleskoplardan biri.
Bütün teleskoplar buna göre
kendini ölçeklendirir.
Bu teleskop, Apache Point Gözlemevi
New Mexico'da.
Kurulduktan, faaliyete geçtikten sonra
bir ayda insanlığın o kurulana kadar
ürettiği bütün astronomi bilgisi kadar
bilgi üretti bu teleskop.
Daha fazla bilgi üretti.
Ama bir şey daha var.
10 yıl sonra, insanlık tarihinde üretilmiş
bütün bilgiden daha fazla veri topladı.
Bu bilginin içinde sadece bilim yok.
İlyada var, Dede Korkut var,
Çin masalları da var.
Bütün bilgi, insanlık tarihindeki.
Bunun nasıl korkunç bir şey
olduğunu düşünebiliyor musunuz?
İşte bu, arkadaşlar,
big data dediğimiz şey.
Fakat insanoğlu burada durmuyor.
Bu gördüğünüz ALMA. Şili'de.
Daha tam resmi açılışı yapılmadı.
Fakat veri topluyor. İlk kez kara maddeyi
bulduk orada onun sayesinde.
Bu ALMA, 66 ayrı teleskop,
tek bir teleskop gibi çalışıyor.
Aralarında mesafe açılıyor,
taşınıyorlar altta gördüğünüz gibi.
Her biri tonlarca onun, eğer tek bir
mekana, küçük bir yıldıza
veya bir tek nebulaya bakacaksak
onları birbirine yaklaştırıyoruz.
Eğer bir galaksiye bakacaksak
aralarını açıyoruz.
Tek bir süper bilgisayarın -saniyede
1,5 trilyon işlem yapan bir bilgisayarın-
tek bir görevi var. Milimetre olarak bu
yerinden kıpırdadı mı ona bakıyor.
Milimetre olarak kıpırdarsa
veriler yanlış.
66'sını birden saniyede 2 kez
kontrol ediyor.
Bu teleskop, her 5 günde insanlık
tarihindeki bütün veri kadar bilgiyi
-bakın öbürü 10 yılda toplamıştı-
bu 5 günde yapacak bunu.
Düşünebiliyor musunuz nasıl
bir şeyin altındayız.
İşte bu bilimsel patlama 2 şey.
Ben bir bilim programı yapıyorum
ekonomi müdürü olarak.
Dalga geçiyor benimle insanlar.
Bir bilim programı yapıyorum
pazartesiden perşembeye.
Reyting rekorları kırıyorum
takdir edersiniz ki.
Türk halkı hep bilim izlemek ister,
hep teknoloji izlemek ister.
Asla bizi evlendir, kaynanam ne yaptı
izlemez Türk halkı.
Türk halkına RTÜK soruyor.
Ne izliyorsunuz?
Belgesel.
Ne izlemek istiyorsunuz?
İyi de niye belgesellerin reytingleri
düşük de, biri birinin başını yardı,
biri bilmem ne oldunun
reytingleri yüksek?
Onları kara maddeler
izliyor ben biliyorum.
Şimdi orada seyredebilirsiniz,
insan zihnine yolculuk yapıyoruz.
İki büyük proje. Bir tanesi
Avrupa Birliği'nin projesi.
Beyninizde ne olup bitiyor?
Öbürü de Amerika'nın projesi.
İnsan beyni projesi ikisi.
Arkadaşlar, kendi anılarınızı
televizyonda izleyebileceksiniz.
Ben, anılarınızı bana
seyrettirebilir misiniz diye
bir şey yaptım, internet sitemizde
bulabilirsiniz.
Düşüncelerinizi evet uçurabilirsiniz.
Şu anda kumanda kolu sadece
düşünce gücüyle sağa ve sola ittiriliyor.
Ama yakında her şey mümkün olacak.
Bilimsel patlamanın birisi üç boyutlu
yazıcılar, inanılmaz bir şey.
Eviniz bir fabrikaya dönüşecek.
Mars'ta ya da Türkiye'de,
Etiler'de ya da Serez'de
olmanızın bir önemi olmayacak.
Saatin kaç olduğunun önemi yok.
Her şeyi yazacaksınız.
İkincisi, insan genomu kopyalandı.
Ölümsüzlüğün kapıları açılıyor.
Ben bundan çok korkuyorum. Çünkü ben,
insanoğlunun kibrinden çok korkuyorum.
İnsanoğlu, çok kibirli bir şey.
Çok kibirli.
Kendini bütün evren onun için yaratıldı,
her şey ondan değersiz.
Mesela ben vejetaryenim,
bir yerlere gidince -yer vermeyeyim-
özellikle et yenen bölgelere gidince
"Ama Emin bey,
bunlar bizim için yaratıldı."
İyi. Aslanlar da sizi yiyince Savana'da,
köpek balıkları saldırınca
hiç demiyorsunuz "Biz onlar
için yaratıldık."
Ne işiniz var oralarda?
Öyle bir şey yok arkadaşlar.
İnsanoğlu kibirli. Kendine tanrı rolü
vermeye çok müsait bir kibir yaratığı.
Bundan arınmak lazım.
İşte bu beni korkutuyor.
Ama bir şey daha var.
Zamanımız var mı?
Elinizdeki cep telefonları, radarlar
üretilemeyecek 40 yıl içinde.
Neden?
Elemetler tablosunu hatırlar mısınız?
Unutmak istiyorsunuz biliyorum onları
ama onları hatırlayın.
O elementler tablosunun altındakiler
nadir elementler.
40 yıl içinde bitecekler. 40 yıl içinde
ve insanlık hazırlık yapıyor.
4 tane derin uzay madenciliği
şirketi var şu anda. Dört.
Biri astronotların kurduğu, biri
Google'ın ortaklarından birinin kurduğu.
Dört tane. Düşünebiliyor musunuz?
Ne yapmayı hedefliyorlar?
Elysium diye bir film vardı,
seyreden var mı?
O filmde şöyle, zenginler uzaya giderler,
dünya çok kötü durumda.
Sıradan, vasat bir film.
Zenginler, Dünya'nın çevresinde
kurulan şehirlere giderler.
Arkadaşlar, 5 kilometre çapında
bir asteroid, 1,5 ile 4 trilyon dolar
arasında maden içeriyor.
Bunu bulup hangi asteroidler
maden içeriyor -Mars ile Jüpiter'in
arasındadır asteroid kuşağı-
bunu Dünya'nın yörüngesine,
Lagrange yörüngesi dediğimiz
Dünya-Ay sisteminin dışına getirecekler.
İşleyecekler ve biz de aşağıdan bakacağız.
(Gülüşmeler)
İşte benim itirazım buna.
Yoksa benim itirazım
başka hiçbir şeye değil.
Benim muhalefetim buna,
başka bir şeye değil.
Paul Verlaine'in bu şiirini
ben çok önemsiyorum.
Ey sen ki durmadan ağlarsın,
Döversin dizlerini
Gel söyle ne yaptın,
Nettin gençliğini?
Arkadaşlar, ne yaptınız?
Yarın için ne yaptınız?
Bir devlet için 2030, 2040 hiçbir şey.
Hiçbir şey.
Hesap sorun. Vatandaş hesap sorar,
kul itaat eder.
Ben size son cümle olarak
şunu söyleyeyim.
Katiyetle politik bir anlamda söylemiyorum
Başkası da olsaydı aynı olacaktı.
Çünkü vatandaş yok.
Vatandaş hesap sormuyor.
Hindistan, Mars'ın yörüngesine
sonda yolladı.
Mars'ın yörüngesine.
Çin başarısız olmuştu.
Rusya, Avrupa Birliği ve Amerika'dan sonra
Hindistan dördüncü ülke oldu.
Bunu iki kez yayınladım.
Ne kadar maliyeti?
74 milyon dolar.
Biz 600 milyon dolara saray yapıyoruz,
150 milyon dolara uçak alıyoruz.
Bakın, bunu başkası da olsaydı
başka türlü harcayacaktı.
Bilime harcamayacaktı,
akla harcamayacaktı.
Yani bunu bir şeye muhalefet
olarak söylemiyorum.
Hepimizin, sizin hesap sormanız lazım,
benim paramı nereye?
Dünyada demokrasi nasıl geldi?
Bilen var mı?
Magna Carta.
Magna Carta demokrasi değildir arkadaşlar.
Magna Carta, kralın vergi koyma
hakkının sınırlanmasıdır.
Benim vergimi ne yaptın
diye parlamento hesap sorar.
Savaşa mı harcadın, nereye harcadın?
Lütfen paralarımızın bilime, akla,
çocuklarımıza, eğitime harcanması için
baskı yapın. Başka bir yere harcanmasın.
Sürem bitti.
Çok teşekkür ediyorum. İyi ki varsınız,
iyi ki buradasınız. Sağ olun.
(Alkışlar)